GOOD
MORNING- I AM CALLING THIS
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER AS
A SUB COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW
ACTUALLY WE CAN START AS A FULL
COMMITTEE WE CAN AGAIN START AS
A FULL COMMITTEE- WELL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HERE.
O'DONNELL HERE ADULT HERE KILEY
BENNETT HERE SENATE HERE DALLY.
DALLY HERE PLEASE LEAVE HERE
MCCARTY CORK SILVA. WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM OF CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED ELECT WELCOME THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE FIVE BILL FIVE
BILLS ON FILE THERE IS ONE
MEASURE ON CONSENT TODAY THAT
BILL ON CONSENT IS SB TWO FIVE
FOUR PLEASE NOTE THAT WILL BE
HEARING BILLS AND FILE ORDER.
IN ORDER TO MOVE THROUGH OUR
CHEN EFFICIENTLY WILL ATTEMPT
TO SPEND NO MORE THAN TWENTY
MINUTES ON EACH BILL TWENTY
MINUTES ON EACH BILL AND IT
MEANS TEN MINUTES ON THE PHONE
ONLY TO GO TO THE PHONE FOR TEN
MINUTES ONLY THAT SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. WELL BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR AGENDA I HAVE A
STATEMENT TO READ REGARDING OUR
PROCESS TODAY. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THEM WE ARE RECALL-
WE ARE REQUIRING THAT MASS BE
WORN BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. TESTIFYING IN PERSON IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A MASS WE WILL
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. I DON'T
LIKE THESE MASS BUT- I'VE GOT
TO FOLLOW THE RULES THAT I
DIDN'T ESTABLISHMENT IS WHAT IT
IS PEOPLE RIGHT. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL YOU
MAY APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
WHEN WE INVITE COMMENTS FROM
PEOPLE INSIDE THE ROOM. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR TESTIMONY
THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR SCREEN AS YOU
WATCH. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS. BEGINNING
THEIR PRESENTATION SO IN OTHER
WORDS WAIT TILL THE BILL IS
BEING PRESENTED THAT YOU WANT
TO COMMENT ON. TO GET ON THE
PHONE. OTHERWISE YOU'LL BE ON
ANOTHER BILL. AND WE WILL NOT
YOU WON'T GET. TO THE
OPPORTUNITY AWARENESS S. AS
YOU. AS YOU SO DESIRE. PLEASE
ALLOW THE MODERATORS- PLEASE.
FOLLOW THE MODERATORS
INSTRUCTIONS TO THE WILL
TESTIFY ON THE CORRECT BILL.
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE IS IMPORTANT ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
SEVEN. THERE'S ALSO REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN CAPITOL
PARK. ON THE NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL YOU CAN WALK UP THERE
AND TESTIFY FROM THAT LOCATION
JUST OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL. THE
COMMITTEE ALSO ACCEPTS WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE- POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU CAN
SUBMITTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. FINALLY I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS DISRUPTIONS TO OUR
HEARING PROCESS. THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RECENTLY EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO OUR
COMMITTEE OF FOR PROCEEDINGS.
ON THAT THIS. DISTURB HER
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING A MASK AND
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN TIME
ALLOTTED EXTENDING DISCUSSION
EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR THE BILL AND
OTHER DISRUPTIVE ACTS SAME GOES
FOR THE PHONE IF YOU. IF YOU
COME ON THE PHONE AND WILL YOU
ARE ONLY THERE TO STATE YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OR OR OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE THAT'S ALL YOU
STATE YOU STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY ANYTHING MORE YOU
WILL BE CUT OFF. THE WITNESSES
ARE THOSE FOLKS- AND THEY KNOW
WHO THEY ARE- WHO ARE GOING TO
TESTIFYING FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. THE GAME- I'M GONNA
MOVE ALONG HERE WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE TO OUR FIRST AUTHOR CENTER
ROOM NO IT IS NOT SENATE
REVIEWS CENTERED LEYVA WHO
CHAIRS EDUCATION COMMISSION IS
HERE ON TIME LET THE RECORD
REFLECT THAT SHE SHOWED UP ON
TIME. K. AND THEY SHE IS- BRING
FORWARD SB THREE SIX THREE IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO YOU MAY PERCEIVE
WHEN READY. AGAIN TO THOSE
WITNESSES- BETTER TESTIFYING
THE AT TWO MINUTES- SUPPORT
OPPOSITION- INTO AGAIN THOSE
FOLKS ON THE PHONE- THAT JUST
WAIT JUST WEST AWAY AND YOU
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TWO MINUTES KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE. THEY HAVE BEEN.
THEY'VE COMMUNICATED WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR COULD
MORNING MEMBERS. SENATE BILL
THREE SIXTY THREE WILL ENSURE
THAT THE AMERICAN LEGION AND
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
SIMILAR ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
TO ALL STUDENTS. AS WELL AS NOT
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON GENDER.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL FOR
OTHERS CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF
PROVIDING EQUITABLE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. TO ALL STUDENTS
BY REQUIRING BOTH BOYS STATE
AND GIRLS STATE PROGRAMS TO
OFFER. SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
CROSS CURRICULUM. SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND FACILITIES AN
EQUAL NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GIRLS TO PARTICIPATE AS
THERE ARE FOR BOYS. ANY
LIMITATION ON THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS NOMINATED PER SCHOOL
SHALL APPLY TO BOTH PROGRAMS.
AND ALLOW NON BINARY STUDENTS
TO APPLY TO EITHER PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG HELD THAT
ACCESS TO EDUCATION IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR ALL
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
GENDER. SADLY YOUNG WOMEN
PARTICIPATING CALIFORNIA GIRL
STATE ARE NOT AFFORDED
COMPATIBLE CIVIC EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. AS YOUNG MEN AND
CALIFORNIA BOYS STATE. EVERY
YEAR WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
PANDEMIC. APPROXIMATE THOUSAND
YOUNG MEN PARTICIPATE IN BOYS
STATE AND VISIT SACRAMENTO. AT
THE STATE CAPITOL DURING THE
SUMMER. ON THE OTHER HAND
CALIFORNIA GIRL STATE WITH THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES ERA CAP OF
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY PARTICIPANTS. ARE ABLE TO
PARTAKE IN SOME OF THE ASPECTS
OF CIVIC EDUCATION. BUT NOT
HAVE BEEN NOT BEEN AFFORDED AT
THE SAME ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
TO THEIR GOVERNMENT THAT'S A
VOICE HELP. MOST NOTABLY IN
COMING TO SAN CRIMINAL AND
VISITOR THEIR STAY CAPITOL. ONE
CANNOT DIED THE CAN CANNOT DENY
THAT THE PROGRAM'S PRESENTS AND
SACRAMENTO A FOURTH
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STUDENTS MAY
NOT OTHERWISE HAVE. OTHER
INEQUITIES ALSO EXIST SUCH AS
APPLICATION FEES REGISTRATION
FEES. CAREER FAIRS AND THE
LEARNING OF OUTDATED SONGS THAT
FOCUS MORE ON THE PARENTS OF
YOUNG WOMEN. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT YOUNG WOMEN ARE OFFERED
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AND SAME
TYPE OF EXPOSURE TO GOVERNMENT
AS YOUNG MEN. IN THE WORDS OF
SALLY RIDE THE FIRST WOMAN IN
SPACE YOU CANNOT BE WHAT YOU
CANNOT SEE. SO IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT YOUNG WOMEN ARE
NOT DISADVANTAGED AND ARE ALSO
ABLE TO VISIT THE HALLS OF
POWER IN SACRAMENTO. AND THE
CAPITAL IF THE YOUNG MEN
PARTICIPATING BOYS STATE DO. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
AMERICAN LEGION AND AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY AND BOTH HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AFTER AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS JESSICA STENDER
WITH EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
AND SHALL BE EGGED ON A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GIRLS STATE
ALUMNI. AND WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABOUT. THERE THE BILL'S
MOVED AND SECONDED LET'S GO TO
YOUR FIRST WITNESS- MISS CENTER
I BELIEVE STENDER CENTER.
CENTER CENTER I APOLOGIZE YEAH
PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING AND A CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JESSICA STENDER SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR WORKPLACE JUSTICE
AND PUBLIC POLICY EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB THREE SIX THREE.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE GENDER
BASED INEQUITY THAT IS
PERPETUATED BY OUTDATED
EXCEPTION TO PROTECT
COMBINATION COEFFICIENTS USING
PROHIBITION THAT OUR STATE
EDUCATION CODE. IS ACCEPTABLE
PROGRAMS OR ACTIVITIES OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION AND SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION RELATED
TO THE BOYS AND GIRLS THE
CONFERENCE. WAS INCLUDED
AMERICAN MILLER EXCEPTION
ENTITLED LINE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THE EXCEPTION UNDER TITLE
NINE OF THE RESULT OF HE
POLITICAL COMPROMISE. IT MIGHT
HAVE ARGUABLY BEEN INTENDED TO
EASE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
AMERICAN LEGION INTO A NEW ERA
OF LEGALLY MANDATED EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS HOWEVER ANY
SUCH RATIONALE DEVOID OF
LEGITIMACY AND AS FAR OUTLIVED
ANY PURPORTED JUSTIFICATION.
THIS IS SPECIALLY TRUE WANTED
RESULTED IN GENDER BASED
INEQUITIES THAT ARE CONTRARY TO
THE INTENT AND PURPOSE OF OUR
STATE EDUCATION. CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWS- WOULD SURE THAT THE
PROGRAMS SUSTAINED SIMILAR
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS EQUAL ACT
TO GO OFFICIALS AND IT'S REALLY.
EQUAL NUMBER TICKETS AND FULL
ACCESS AND NON BINARY STUDENTS.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO BRING THE
GIRLS PROGRAM UP TO PAR WITH
THE BOYS PROGRAM AND IT WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH BILL. AND
THEN THERE WERE MORE WOMEN
AROUND THAN EVER RUNNING FOR
OFFICE. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOW
THE WAY AND HELPING THESE
PROGRAMS CREATE A PIPELINE OF
YOUNG WOMEN THAT WE WANT TO RUN
FOR OFFICE. ALLOWING GENDER
DISCRIMINATION ESPECIALLY WHILE
USING PUBLIC RESOURCES AND
ENGAGING WITH OUR- STATE
LEGISLATURE FLIES IN THE FACE
OF THE VALUES OF OUR STATE. SB
THREE SIX THREE PROVIDE A PATH
TO CREATING A MUCH NEEDED
CHANGE THE PROGRAM. AND ENSURE
THAT OUR EDUCATION EQUITY LAW
LIVES UP TO ITS PURPOSE. OF
PREVENTING SEX DISCRIMINATION
IN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES FOR THESE REASONS.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU TO THE NAY.
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SHELBY AND DAHLE I ATTENDED
GIRLS STATE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND RETURNED AS A
JUNIOR COUNSELOR IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WHEN I FIRST
ATTENDED GIRLS STATE I FOUND
THE PROGRAM TO BE EMPOWERING I
WAS SO EXCITED TO BE SELECTED
TO REPRESENT MY SCHOOL IN SUCH
A PRESTIGIOUS PROGRAM. I LOVED
LEARNING ABOUT GOVERNMENT SUCH
A GREAT COMMUNITY OF AMBITIOUS
YOUNG WOMEN FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. BUT THEN I CAME BACK
FROM GROWTH STATE AND LEARNED
ABOUT WHAT MY MALE
COUNTERPARTS. AT BOISE STATE.
NOT ONLY WAS IT A LARGER
PROGRAM WITH TWO BOYS FROM MY
SCHOOL ATTENDING REGULARLY
COMPARED TO THE ONE ATTENDING
GIRLS STATE. BUT THEY KNOW THAT
THE CAPITOL VISITORS ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OFFICERS AND
MEDICS AFRICAN REPRESENTATIVE.
THEY PARTICIPATED IN A CLEAR
NIGHT COLLEGE OFFICIALS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THEY WERE EVEN
AWARDED CERTIFICATE. TRACKING
RISING ARCHING BACK. NONE OF
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY WERE FOR
THAT. I THOUGHT LIKE WOULD. IN
THE LAST FIVE WITH AND OF THEIR
I'LL BE OPTION PURELY BECAUSE
OF GENDER. WITHOUT EXPOSURE AND
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES THE
BOYS RECEIVED. SO MANY DOORS
THAT WERE OPEN TO THAT. MORE
PEOPLE ARE LEFT WALKED US. I
THOUGHT BACK TO INAPPROPRIATE
SAMBA GROWTH ABOUT. FORTY
CRAZINESS AND TALKING A GIRL
STATE CORAL WALKING DOWN THE
STREET. TRADITIONS OF THE
PROGRAM'S OUTDATED STRUCTURE.
WHEN I JUST GOT THE LOCATION
ISSUE WITH DIFFERENT CULTURES
EIGHT STAFF MEMBERS I WAS TOLD
MANY DIFFERENT COMPETING
ANSWERED THAT ALL COULD NOT
BELIEVE. THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO CHANGE BECAUSE IT'S
INCONVENIENT. AND NOT THE
OPERATOR. EVEN WHEN I PUT THE
EFFORT IN ADAM AND HER AT THE
CAPITOL TO GET CERTIFICATES FOR
GIRLS SKATERS. EVER PROVIDED ME
WITH THE INFORMATION YOU THAT
DESPITE BEING LATE WHAT WITH
MULTIPLE CHECK IN FOR ME. THIS
IS A CHANGE. THE MILLIONS OF
YOUNG WOMEN IN THE STATE IS
THAT BETTER. I NEEDED ABOUT
DEATH ON THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
ARE WILL NOW GO TO ANY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION. THE
HEARING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE'LL NOW GO TO ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS ON
THE BILL NOT SINGLE QUESTIONS
ON THE BILL. THIS CALL. GOOD
MORNING SO I ATTENDED GIRLS
STATE AND BOTH OF OUR SONS ARE
BOYS STATE- THEY BOTH ATTENDED
AND MY FATHER IS HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN THE NORTH STATE AND
RECRUITMENT SO WHEN I SAW SO I
WAS. CONFUSED TO BE HONEST
BECAUSE THESE ARE TWO SEPARATE
ENTITIES AND THEY'VE BUILT
THESE PROGRAMS OUT PARALLEL TO
EACH OTHER SO THAT ALTHOUGH
THEY MAY BE AFFILIATED THEIR
NONPROFITS. AND SO WHEN WE WHEN
I QUESTIONED- YOU KNOW WHAT WHY
ARE WE INVOLVED IN THIS WELL SO
IT'S THE RECORD I WANT TO BE
CLEAR IT'S A RECRUITMENT FROM
THE SCHOOLS THAT MAKES THIS.
THE INVOLVEMENT OKAY. SO
RECRUITMENT FOR MY FATHER
INCLUDES WALKING AND HANDING
HAS. SLIPPED TO THE YOU KNOW
FLYERS THE PRINCIPLE TO SAY
LET'S REMEMBER. THIS IS COMING
UP WE NEED KIDS IT'S VERY
ACTUALLY HARDER TO RECRUIT THAN
YOU CAN IMAGINE AS I'M SPEAKING
FOR THAT OUR STATE I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. SO
IT'S ALSO MORE EXPENSIVE TO
SEND GIRLS FROM THE NORTH STATE.
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO. FORCED PROGRAMS THAT
ARE NONPROFIT PROGRAMS TO
RELOCATE TO A DIFFERENT CAMPUS
BECAUSE THE REASON THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO. THE CAPITALS
BECAUSE THERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. CORRECT NO- WE HAVE
LOTS OF YOUNG MEN FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE PART OF BOYS
STATE THE TRAVEL UP TO THE
CAPITAL RIGHT BUT THE GIRLS
STATE PROGRAM IS LOCATED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO THAT IT
WAS SO PART OF THEIR PROGRAM IS
A BUILT OUT TO ATTEND LIKE WE
SEE THE BOYS STATE THAT WILL BE
HERE I THINK THIS WEEK
ACTUALLY. AND THEY WILL BE
THROUGH THE HALLS SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING THE AMERICAN
THE AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY
TO RELOCATE THEIR CONFERENCE.
TO SACRAMENTO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO BUT IF THEY DON'T THEN THE
BOYS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
SACRAMENTO. THIS IS JUST
STRICTLY ABOUT EQUITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT BOTH PROGRAMS.
OFFER THE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
PROGRAMS. THAT YOU KNOW YOU
THINK ABOUT IT SO IF THEY HAVE
TO CHANGE THE PROGRAM YES. WE
WORK WITH THE AUXILIARY THAT IS
OPPOSITION. THEY ARE IN SUPPORT
NOW- IT CAN YOU JUST THINK
ABOUT IT SO AS A PART OF THE
STARTED FOR ME. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WHEN I WOULD SEE THE THOUSANDS
OF BOYS ARE HUNDREDS OF BOYS
COMING TO BOISE STATE UP HERE
AND I SAID WHY DON'T THE GIRLS
ALLOWED ONE OF THE GIRLS HERE.
AND I DON'T KNOW THE GIRLS
AREN'T ALLOWED TO COME NICE
WHAT SEEMS WRONG. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE THIRTY EIGHT FEMALE
LEGISLATORS. WHICH IS THE MOST
WE HAVE HAD IN HISTORY OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY. WE NEED
MORE WOMEN COMING SO THEY CAN
SEE THAT THEY CAN BE IN THE-
ASSEMBLY THAT THEY CAN BE IN
THE SENATE. SO YES THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE THE
PROGRAM AND LIKE I SAID THE
AMENDMENTS WE'VE TAKEN HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SO I AGREE THAT WE NEED
EQUITY AND- I'M- A WOMAN. TO A
POSITION. BUT- I THINK OR ME.
I WON'T BE SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
IT'S- WE CAN JUST. MAYBE NOT
RECRUITING MORE OUT OF THE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE
ASKING A NONPROFIT WHO'S BEEN
DOING THIS SUCCESSFULLY FOR
DECADES AND YES OR NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVEMENTS I AGREE. BUT
THERE'S NO GOVERNMENT MONEY
THERE ARE IN THESE PROGRAMS
THERE'D WE DON'T FIND THIS. AND
A GIRL SAY IS JUST GROSSLY
UNDER FUNDED AND THAT'S JUST
COMING OUT OF THE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE NONPROFIT ITSELF SO.
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONTROL
OVER HERE OTHER THAN IF WE WANT
TO GET INVOLVED OURSELVES AND
HELP FUND THOSE PROGRAMS WHICH
THEY DO. AND THEN OUR STATE. SO
THANK YOU. FOR THAT AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT I THINK WE HAVE
TO DEFINE SUCCESS. IF THE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
THE IN MY OPINION I DON'T THINK
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THESE YOUNG WOMEN
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SEE THEIR GOVERNMENT. ACTION
THEY'RE SINGING SONGS THE ARE
VERY HONESTLY VERY DEMEANING.
AND SO I. THAT MAYBE THAT
SUCCESS WAS IN THE FIFTIES AND
SIXTIES. BUT WE HAVE TO CHANGE
AS A SOCIETY WE HAVE TO GET
BETTER AND THIS BILL IS JUST
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING THAT FOR THE GIRLS AS
WELL AS THE YOUNG MAN. GOOD MR
LINK. IT IS TOO LATE. I SCITECH
DAUGHTER FOR BRING US FOR IT I
ALSO KNEW THE SIMILAR THING
WHEN I WAS STAFF AND I WOULD
SET MY BOSSES BIGGER VOICE
STATE AND I WOULD ASK OF ONE OF
THE GIRLS COMING OFF AND IF
THEY DON'T COME UP AS A LOT. OF
SOMETHING TO MAYBE TO ADDRESS
MY COLLEAGUES POINT TO IS I
KNOW IN MY NOTES THAT GIRL
STATE HAS 50% FEWER APPLICANTS
AND THEY ALSO PAY A SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLAR APPLICATION FEE
WELL BOYS STATE THEY'LL PAY
ANYTHING AND IT'S DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE SO THERE IS AN
UNFAIRNESS THERE TO THAT POINT
YET SO HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE FUNDING
ISSUE BY HAVING A CRUEL PAY
STRUCTURES LAW OF COURSE YOU
KNOW. THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS A LOT
FOR YOUNG PERSON BUT HOPEFULLY
A FEW MORE EQUITABLY DISPERSED
THAT WAY I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHAT- EQUITY MEASURE
TO BRING FEMALE STUDENTS UP
HERE AS WELL AS WELLS AND I
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING NON
BINARY SINCE AS WELL AND THIS
IS A RELEASE TO MODERNIZE OUR
PROGRAM MAKE SURE IT. AND SHOW
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT THE HALLS OF
POWER NOT JUST FOR THAT ANYMORE
SO I THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I THINK I
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD HIM SAY MR
ALWAYS GONNA HELP YOU GET ONEY
IN. THE BUDGET NEXT YEAR FOR
GIRLS STATE. BUT I HEARD. THIS
COURT SILVA. GOOD MORNING TO
HIM AND SENATOR YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL YOU KNOW I
THINK THIS BILL. THE CIVICALLY
TALKS ABOUT. GIRLS AND BOYS
STATE BUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
MEN OR WOMEN RELATED TO NON
PROFITS AND- WE'VE SEEN. RISE
TO THE STATE LEVEL ACTIONS BY
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY RELATED TO
BOYS AND GIRL SCOUTS RELATED TO
EVEN FOUR H. PROGRAMS THINGS
LIKE THAT BECAUSE- IT MANY
TIMES AND THEIR EDUCATION
UMBRELLA YOU HAVE THESE VERY
CLOSE PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE
EXISTED FOR. QUITE A LONG TIME
I KNOW THAT TO MYSELF IN THE
CHAIR ACTUALLY ONE OUT TO SEE
SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS AT OUR
HIGH SCHOOL WITH OUR
AGRICULTURE CLUBS AND AGAIN
PUBLIC PRIVATE PROGRAMS SO
SOMETIMES WE INTERVENE. IN WAYS
TO EXTEND THE PROGRAM SOMETIMES
WE INNER VISION AND BUDGET
ASKED TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS. BUT
I WOULD SAY. GROWING UP IN
FULLER TEN A COMING FROM US OF.
HIGHER ED I WAS THE FOR IN MY
FOR. NONE OF THE ANY OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT I MEANT WERE RE
OF A FOR MANY OF OUR UNDER
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OFTEN THESE
PROGRAMS ARE GENERATIONAL IN
THE SENSE THAT. WHETHER IT'S
NATIONAL CHARITY LEAGUE
WEATHER'S BOYS AND GIRLS STATE
THAT IT'S THE FAMILY THAT HAS
BEEN INVOLVED AND THEN THEY OF
COURSE INVOLVED THEIR OWN
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
SOMETIMES THOSE ARE DOOR DOORS
ARE SHUT TO A VERY. UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR BECAUSE NOBODY IN THEIR
FAMILIES EVER BEEN INVOLVED IN
FOUR H. OUR BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
OR A STATE AND I KNOW-
PARTICULARLY AT THE SCHOOLS
WERE THE INVITATIONS ARE MADE
TO WHETHER IT'S THE- GIRL OR
THE YOUNG BOY A LOT OF TIMES
THAT THOSE DECISIONS ARE MADE
AT THE PRINCIPAL. OFFICE OR AT
THE COUNSELOR OFFICE WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY RECOMMEND- THROUGH THE
NONPROFIT AND AGAIN. YOU CAN
THERE IS A PATTERN OF THE SAME
FAMILIES BEING INVITED SO I
SUPPORT THIS BUT I DO THINK AS
WE EVOLVE. THESE MEASURES OF
EQUITY. NOT TO SAY EVERY BOY
AND GIRL IN ANY CLASS WOULD
HAVE THE INTEREST OR EVEN THE
DESIRE TO JOIN BUT MANY TIMES
EVEN AT ITS BEST THEIR VERY
SMALL GROUPS OF THE SAME
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ASTON DO
THESE PROGRAMS SO. I APPRECIATE
THIS AND WANT TO SEE. MY DESIRE
TO IS TO SEE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
NOT TO EXCLUDE EXCLUDE ONE
GROUP BUT TO INCLUDE MORE SO
THANK YOU AND I DO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MISTER BENNETT. IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THERE IT IS SOME
RESPONSIBILITY ON THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN THIS
KIND OF SITUATION TO LOOK AT
THEIR ORGANIZATION AND IF. SO I
WOULD SAY THE BOYS STATE. HAVE
SOME. TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE IS EQUAL ACCESS TO
THE FEMALES IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR IF
THEY'RE GOING TO USE- PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AS A RECRUITMENT TOOL
AND THAT JUST AS A- AS A COMMON
SENSE SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM-
I APPRECIATE TO THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THEIR IF NOT THE SAME
RESOURCES AND HOW THEY DO IT
BUT THAT'S- THAT'S- I THINK THE
BURDEN OF ANYBODY PROVIDING A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS EQUAL
ACCESS THANK YOU. THINK THANK
YOU A SINGLE FOR THE COMMITTEE
COME OUT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES
FOR TEN MINUTES. TO THE PHONES
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ACTUALLY IT
WOULD BE AN HOUR OR OPPOSITION
IT SHOULD BE MIXED IF I'M
CORRECT YET SO IN OTHER WORDS
OKAY THEY SUPPORT OR OPPOSE YOU
MAY YOU MAY COME ON THE PHONE
YOU STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
AS THAT IS WHAT YOU DO NOW
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR CLARIFYING THIS CARE-
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR SB
THREE SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AT THIS-TIME EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFF LINE
IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AT WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PARDON MY FRENCH
TEACHER THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT THE AND THE WITNESS HAS
TESTIFIED. OKAY THERE ARE
STRONG AND GROWING ALONG TIME
SENATORS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOT PLEASE MOVE ON. REMEMBER
AGAIN WHAT YOU YOU IF YOU ARE
ON THE PHONE OR YOU CAN DO IS
YOU CAN COME AND YOU CAN STATE
YOUR NAME IF YOU'RE AFFILIATED
WITH AN ORGANIZATION SAY SO IF
YOU'RE NOT INSTANCES IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL SO OKAY
YOUR GENERATED TESTIFIED AND
STATE YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY. PLEASE PROCEED I WENT AT
IT CONNECTED HIM- WHICH I MADE
GO AHEAD HIT ONE ZERO AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE SIR.
I LINE EIGHTEEN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
EVERYBODY ELSE SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND IT'S
CLEAR WE HAVE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WE OVER GET BACK-
WE'VE HAD COMMITTEE COMMENT. WE
HAD A MOTION AND A SECOND- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY- AS NECESSARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CLOSE- YOU MAY
CLOSE YOUR EYES ARE GOING TO
SAY THAT YOU KNOW WHEN I
BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD I
THOUGHT IT WAS RELATIVELY
SIMPLE THAT WE JUST WANTED
EQUITY FOR GIRLS IN THIS
PROGRAM AND I WAS ABSOLUTELY
SHOCKED AT HOW MUCH OPPOSITION
WE GOT FROM THE AMERICAN
LEGION- THEY EVER MOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION BUT ADDITIONALLY. I
HAD BOYS WHO GRADUATED VOICE
STATE FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
CALLING ME TELLING ME THAT I
WAS GOING TO BE RUINING THE
VOICE STATE PROGRAM BY MAKING
SURE THAT IT WAS EQUITABLE FOR
GIRLS AND IT WAS JUST REALLY
SHOCKING TO ME HOW INCREDIBLY
SEXIST IT WAS AND YOU KNOW MY
HUSBAND COACHED AMERICAN LEGION
FOR MANY MANY YEARS BASEBALL-
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
AMERICAN LEGION FOR MANY YEARS.
SO YOU KNOW AS I SAID TO THEM
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE AMERICAN
LEGION AND INTEGRATING THEM
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
YOUNG WOMEN HAVE THE SAME
EQUITY IN- AS THE BOYS STILL SO
I'M GLAD THAT WE GOT TO A
POSITION WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY HOW SHOCKING IT WAS
IN SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT MY
STAFF HEARD. AND THE CALL THAT
WE GOT IT WAS VERY SURPRISING
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. UNDERSTOOD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS THE PAST TO ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE O'DONNELL
HI. DONNA HI KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTE. SENATE FINANCE I VALLEY.
DALLY NO LEAD LEE MCCARTY QUICK
SILVA HI QUICK SILVA I. GOOGLE
PLUS FOR VOTED AS ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU LET'S
SITE IS MISTER THROUGH A CENTER
RUBIO HERE. WE NEED SENATOR
RUBIO HERE. FAST. YEAH LARA
SENATOR STERN. AREAS EUROPE.
SENATOR STERN AS SB SIX NINE
THREE IT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR NUMBER FOUR. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY MR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'LL BE BRIEF- WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE SEE ON TV AND PEOPLE
STORMING THE CAPITOL WERNICK
SHIRT THAT SAYS CAMP AUSCHWITZ
ON IT AND THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT AUSCHWITZ IS WE KNOW WE
HAVE A PROBLEM- WHEN. THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IS FINALLY
RECOGNIZING AND YOUNG PEOPLE
GROWING UP IN THE HEART OF THE
ARMENIAN DESPERATE. NO CONTEXT
FOR THEIR HISTORY OR WAY TO
SHARE THAT THAT HISTORY WITH-
WITH THEIR FELLOW CLASSMATES
AND FEEL AT HOME IN THEIR
COMMUNITY WE HAVE A PROBLEM. I
THINK THERE'S- THERE'S OF THEIR
STRONG FOUNDATIONS IN OUR
EDUCATION CODE IN IN OUR IN OUR
PRACTICES RIGHT NOW FOR
TEACHING ABOUT GENOCIDE FOR
TEACHING ABOUT HISTORY IT'S
BUILT INTO THE MODEL CURRICULA
BUT WHEN CRISES HAPPEN AT
SCHOOLS WERE LOOKING TO GIVE
TOOLS TO TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
TO DEAL WITH ACTS OF HATE. WITH
HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
SOME SOME TOOLS- TO EMPOWER
FOLKS AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ARE
GETTING TEACHERS EXPERTISE IN
THIS COMMISSION OR ENVISIONING
I THINK WILL BE CRUCIAL FOR THE
PEOPLE OF EXPERIENCE TEACHING
ABOUT THE GENOCIDE. IT'S
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE COALITION AN
IMPORTANT TIME TO REALIZE WHERE
WE COME FROM OR WHAT OUR
HISTORY IS AND HOW MUCH IMPACT
IT HAS ESPECIALLY- IN A TIME OF
RACIAL UPHEAVAL WHEN YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE DRIVING DOWN
THE TEN FREE WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
HIGHWAY AND YOU'RE WONDERING.
WHAT WHAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
COLUMBUS SAILED THE OCEAN BLUE-
WE NEED TO KNOW OUR HISTORIES
OF GENOCIDE IN THIS COUNTRY
AND- WITHOUT IT WILL BE DOOMED
TO REPEAT IT SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WELCOME- THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION
SPONSORSHIP AND LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA I THINK HE'S GOING TO
BE WITH US HERE TO TESTIFY HOPE
WE DIDN'T- RUSSIAN TOO MUCH
BUT- THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
CENTER STARLETS GO TO THE- IT'S
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
OUR SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION. TONY THURMOND IS
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU CHERYL
DONALD R. TWENTY SEVEN STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- ARE THERE TO BE A
SPONSOR. OF THIS BILL AND ASK
THE MEMBERS FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS
YOU HEARD SENATOR TURN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP- THE
SENATOR HAS OUTLINED HIS BILL
ADDRESS MANY ASPECTS OF
GENOCIDE- ARE YOU GOING TO
TEACH ME ABOUT THEM. AND OF
COURSE THE IMPORTANCE OF
TEACHING ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE HOLOCAUST WE'VE SEEN- A
RISE IN ACTS OF HATE- THAT
AFFECTED MANY- INCLUDING IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY POLICING HATE
AND IN MANY WAYS AND THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT THERE IS
INTERCONNECTION. FOR MANY
GROUPS IN THAT WE CAN NEVER
FORGET ANY GENOCIDE AS IT THAT
CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO CREEP UP
AGAIN AND SO- FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED. BEFORE I URGE
YOUR- FOLKS THAT CALIFORNIA
PROCLIVITY CATIONS IS NOT.
WASTE TO HELP SUPPORT THE
STATION OF THIS BILL AND HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMUNITY
WHO HAVE RESOURCES DO YOU DO
WHAT WE CALL EDUCATION. CULTURE
HATE. IT TO COUNTER THE HEAT
THAT OFTEN CAN MANIFEST IN ACTS
OF GENOCIDE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SUPERINTEND
OVER THE NEXT WITNESS- WHICH IS
A MISTER CLIFF BURKE. YOU
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I MISTER
CHAIR CLIFF HERE BEHALF OF
FIRST THE JEWISH PUBLIC. CAN OF
K. WE ARE IN STRONG. OF THIS
LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THE GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL ON GENOCIDE AND THE
HOLOCAUST- DISCOUNTS WILL
PROVIDE ENHANCED RESOURCES FOR
TEACHER TRAINING AND IMPROVE
BEST PRACTICES TO BE UTILIZED
IN THE CLASSROOM. TO REMEDY
RECENT RISE IN ANTI SEMITISM
HOLOCAUST DENIAL AND OTHER ACTS
OF HATRED. THE FACT IS THE
LARGEST SINGLE STATE COALITION
OF JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
NATION REPRESENTING JEWISH
COMMUNITIES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- UNFORTUNATELY
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY REQUIRE AGE
APPROPRIATE INSTRUCTION FOCUSED
ON HOLOCAUST AND GENOCIDE
EDUCATION. INSTEAD THESE TOPICS
ARE GENERALLY COVERED IN THE
GREATER CONTEXT OF WAR WAR TO
THESE CAN RESULT IN ONLY A
SUPERFICIAL OVERVIEW BEING
PRESENTED TO STUDENTS WHICH IN
TURN MINIMIZES THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE HOLOCAUST. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN STUDY
FOUND THAT 41% OF AMERICANS AND
66% OF MILLENNIALS COULD NOT
IDENTIFY THE SIGNIFICANCE OF OX
WHAT'S- THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF MOUNTING EVIDENCE
THAT THE COLLECTIVE MEMORY OF
THE HOLOCAUST. AND THE
SYSTEMATIC EXTERMINATION OF
MILLIONS IS FADING THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS ARE STARK
AND READILY DEMONSTRATED BY THE
RISE IN ANTI SEMITIC SPEECH.
AND HATE CRIMES THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. SB SIX NINE
THREE WILL CONFRONT THIS
PROBLEM BY REQUIRING AGE
APPROPRIATE HOLOCAUST AND
GENOCIDE EDUCATION. TO STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WILL PROVIDE
TEACHERS WITH EXPERT APPROVED
AGE APPROPRIATE EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS AND RESOURCES TO
EDUCATE ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST THE
HARMS OF RACISM. AND BIGOTRY-
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SIMON WIESENTHAL CENTER AND
MUSEUM OF TALL HOLOCAUST AND
WOULD SAY IN THEIR BEHALF THE
HOLOCAUST WAS THE WATERSHED
EVENT OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
AND YET THE MEMORY OF THIS
OBSCENITY FADES TOGETHER WITH
THE COURAGEOUS SURVIVORS- IT'S
ASTOUNDING THE INTERNS OF SO
MANY AMERICANS TODAY AND YOUNG
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR OF THE
HISTORY OF THE HOLOCAUST IN
EVENTS. THAT HAPPENED
SURROUNDING IT. THE INCREASE
RISE IN ANTI SEMITISM
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES IN
ACTS OF VIOLENCE HARASSMENT
VANDALISM ASSAULTS IN INTERNET
COMMENTS. OF ANY ANTI SEMITIC
IN NATURE DR DRIVE HOME THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LEGISLATION
ON BEHALF OF G. PACK IN THE
SIMON WIESENTHAL CENTER. URGES
YOUR AYE VOTE IN. STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE ANY OPPOSITION
SEEING OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I'LL JUST
MAKE A QUICK COMMENT MISTER
BIRD BROUGHT UP ACTUALLY. AND
THAT IS RESOURCES ONE OF THE
MISSIONS OF THIS BILLS TO GET
A- THIS COMMISSION TO- ARE THE
COUNCIL. TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO SCHOOLS AND AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER I WANT RESOURCES ALWAYS
I DON'T E. LESSON PLANS AND I
NEED SOMEONE TO WRITE UP A
LESSON PLAN FOR ME WHAT I LIKE
A RESOURCES THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
TO ME. BECAUSE IT HELPS ME-
IT'S MUCH QUICKER RIGHT I GO TO
WEBSITE THERE'S VIDEO THERE- IN
THIS INSTANCE ON THINGS THAT
ARE PRETTY GRAPHIC BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T. REMOVE THOSE PICTURES
FROM YOUR MEMORY AND THAT'S
WHAT. AND THAT'S EVIDENCE NO
ONE CAN DENY THAT SOME MAY BUT
THEY SHOULDN'T RIGHT WE KNOW
THIS WE KNOW THIS EVER IN
RECENT HISTORY BUT AT THE SAME
TIME I APPRECIATE THE FOCUS AS
A CLASSROOM TEACHER. ON THE
RESOURCES BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I
NEED I NEED TO GO TO ANY PLACE
TO GO TO. DESIGN MY LESSON I
DON'T WANNA SPEND TWO HOURS ON
IT RIGHT IF I CAN GO TO ONE
WEBSITE IT'S ALL THERE. YEAH
THAT'S THAT THAT HELPS ME HELP
MY STUDENTS- BECOME INFORMED
AND LEARN SO THANK YOU FOR THE
FOCUS ON RESOURCES RESOURCES
BUT THAT ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
I'M ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISH TO SPEAK MISTER
BENNETT. I WOULD I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ECHO YOUR COMMENT- AS
AN ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL CHARGE
OF CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTION
THAT WAS THE BIGGEST REQUESTED
CAME FROM SOCIAL STUDIES
TEACHERS- OVER OVER AGAIN- AND
I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE SPOT ON
WHEN YOU SAY RESOURCES IS THE
THING TO FOCUS ON TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE. THE BEST EDUCATION
pKNOW MISTER SO. L. FAMOUS QUOTE
THAT WE MANY OF HER THOSE WHO
FORGET THE PAST ARE DOOMED TO
REPEAT IT. I THINK WE'RE LIVING
IN THAT TIME RIGHT NOW- SADLY
AND HORRIFICALLY WE ARE USING
WHAT HAS HAPPENED. DURING THE
HOLOCAUST PERIOD AS A SYMBOL OF
SOME OF TODAY'S FIGHTS WE'VE
SEEN THAT RELATED TO
VACCINATIONS IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE HAD- NOT JUST A FEW BUT MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE TO THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT AND
ED. BOARD WEARING. YELLOW STAR
ACQUAINTING THAT STAR WITH
VACCINE. A POTENTIAL PASSPORTS
AND OF THE LAST YEAR I'VE BEEN
READING SEVERAL NOVELS ON
HISTORICAL FICTION RELATED TO
THE CALL HOLOCAUST AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING TO ME
THAT NOT THAT INDIVIDUALS WOULD
GO TO A BOARD AND TALK ABOUT
POTENTIAL VACCINE PASSPORTS BUT
THAT THEY WOULD USE THE STAR.
AS SOMEHOW THERE'S EVEN AN IOTA
OF SIMILAR. ABUSES KNOWING THE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS. OF JEWS
THAT WERE KILLED KNOWING- THE
HORRIFIC CONDITIONS THEY DIED
UNDER AND IF THIS BILL CAN DO
NO MORE NOTHING MORE THAN UP
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REMEMBER TO RE LEARN TO
UNDERSTAND. IT IS WORTH EVERY
BIT OF- EVERY SCHOOL HAVING A
MOMENT TOUGH START TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE IF WE DO NOT
LEARN. AND IF WE DO NOT REVEAL
LEARN AS ADULTS SOMETIMES WE
HAVE TO RE LEARN THINGS TO EVEN
UNDERSTAND I KNOW AND CONGRESS-
ONE OF THE NEW MEMBERS. MADE
SOME COMMENTS. AND NOW HAS
PUBLICLY APOLOGIZED FOR-
EQUATING. THE HOLOCAUST AND
WHAT HAPPENED THERE AS SIMILAR
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY SO
I'M- SUPPORTED WE APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS HERE. THANK YOU A
SINGLE FURTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE- WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS- ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM ON THIS
BILL. SINGLE PUBLIC CALLING THE
NUMBER OF THE PHONE LINES NEXT
AND ON THE PHONES WHAT YOU CAN
DO IS TAKE YOUR NAME IF YOU'RE
AFFILIATED WITH ANY
ORGANIZATION SURE THAT YOU NEED
NOT BE AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. IS NOT A TIME FOR
FURTHER COMMENT OTHER THAN YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL ON THE PHONES NOW PLEASE.
FOR TEN MINUTES. THANK CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO- SHOW SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX NINE
THREE. FOUR EIGHT EIGHT ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ATG CAPITAL
WILL GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER I
FIND THE PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
FOR. PUBLIC COMMENT. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. AND AGAIN AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YEAH THERE'S
ONE WITH AN OPERATOR SHOULD BE
WITH US MOMENTARILY. YOU MUST
HAVE A QUESTION. CARE AND
PROBODY OUTGOING AT ONE ZERO.
AND OUR FIRST PARTICIPANT WILL
BE FROM. PINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. YEAH HI THIS BILL
IN CALLING FROM I CAN THE
ISRAELI AMERICAN CIVIC ACTION
AT WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BY TWENTY YOUR OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE BILL%
GARCIA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WITH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WE ARE GOING TO BE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY RECOMMENDING
OUR MEMBERS FORMALLY SUPPORT
THE BILL GOING FORWARD AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT BALLOT
COMMAND THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. I'M A CARE NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU. WE NEED TO GO
TO- THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION IN CAPITOL PARK NOW AND
THERE'S NO ONE THERE I'M TOLD
SO AS- AND I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
YOU DO ACCEPT THE CUNNINGHAM
INSIDE YOU YES OKAY THEN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE ACCEPTED-
THIS OP YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU RICHARD THANK YOU FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS IN FOR
REALLY GETTING IT HERE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH- THE
COMMITTEE'S MEMBERS WERE
EXCELLENT BY THE WAY
ESPECIALLY. THE IT IS NOT JUST
A TEACHER BUT OF A STUDENT
VOICE ON THIS COUNCIL I WAS
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD. SITTING IN
EIGHTH GRADE AND GEOMETRY
CLASS. FINDING SWASTIKAS
WRITTEN ON MY BACKPACK AND
WIDEOUT. I'M TRYING TO MAKE
SENSE OF THIS I'M JUST LIKE
GETTING READY FOR MY BAR
MITZVAH NORMAL JEWISH KID IN LA.
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT WAS THAT WAS A PIVOTAL
MOMENT IN MY LIFE. I THINK I AM
SO GRATEFUL TO MRS LIKES MY
TEACHER BACK IN EIGHTH GRADE TO
TEACH ME SOCIAL STUDIES.
PUTTING JUST GIVE ME A COPY
ELLIE WE CELLS NIGHT AND SAY
YOU. GO FIGURE IT OUT. BUT WE
BROUGHT SURVIVORS IN THE SCHOOL
AND USE THAT THAT CRISIS MOMENT
WHERE YOU KNOW ONE KIDS GETTING
BULLIED. AND BEAT UP. FOR WHO
THEY ARE AND ACTUALLY TEACH
THROUGH THAT MOMENT. AND SO
WITH THOSE KIND OF RESOURCES
WERE HOPING TO BRING TO BEAR
ANY EXPERTISE. WE CAN TEACH
THROUGH THESE MOMENTS AND NOT
LOSE THOSE LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE KIDS FEEL
ISOLATED BUT IN FACT TURN THEM
INTO LEADERS IN THE FUTURE SO-
WE'RE SEEING THIS PLAY OUT IN
THIS GENERATION WILL NOT LAST
FOREVER SO. YOUR DUTIES HERE
AND- RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
GREAT THANK YOU WANNA TALK
ABOUT RESOURCES- I'M TALK ABOUT
SIDE OF THE BOOK OF COURSE
RIGHT. THIS I USUALLY. TEACH
OUTSIDE THE BOOK PRODUCT BRING
DIFFERENT RESOURCES TO DELIVER
THE CONTENT AND HELP STUDENTS
MASTER THE CONTENT AS THE KIND
OF. STUFF I'M TALKING ABOUT
THAT REALLY I THINK HELPS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER DO THEIR JOB.
ANNALS ONLY HELP OUR STUDENTS.
AND STUFF SAID MATTER YOU. IT'S
AN ACCOUNTING. SO THE BOOK
DOESN'T ALWAYS DO. AND THE
MOTION IS- DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
OF THE WAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER LEE WE HAVE A SECOND BY
MISTER BENNETT IS MOVED AND
SECONDED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS A MANAGE THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS THE
DONALD I DON'T KNOW WHY KILEY
KILEY AYE SENATE VENETI DALLY.
DALLY I BELIEVE. I MCCARTY CORK
SILVA QUICKSILVER I. THUS
YOU THANK YOU WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AS SENATOR RUBIO OUT
THERE. ASSEMBLY BACKERS HERE
WERE. STAND UP GET UP HERE.
SENATE RECORD. WELCOME HERE
THIS IS YOUR MAYBE. FIRST TIME
INTERNALLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
ON HOW MANY DO YOU HAVE A
LOVELY. ANDREA THIS BEAUTIFUL
ROOM VISITS FOR INTERNET. THE
OTHER ROOMS. I'M SURE GREAT
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IT IS NOT A PERCENT
FIRST TIME FOR THIS COMMITTEE I
DON'T THINK THE COMMITTEE ON
THEIR WORKING EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. SB THIS
BILL SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
CREATED DIGITAL EDUCATION
EQUITY PROGRAM OR DEEP. PROVIDE
EQUITABLE EDUCATION TECHNOLOGY
AND NETWORK SUPPORT TO ALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS. OVER
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS YOU KNOW
THE RAPIDLY EVOLVING USE OF
TECHNOLOGY IN ALL ASPECTS OF
OUR SOCIETY- HAS HEIGHTENED THE
NEED FOR EDUCATORS TO OFFERS TO
THE ART INSTRUCTION TO SUPPORT
THE CURRICULUM DIGITAL LITERACY
STANDARDS AND EFFECTIVE REMOTE
OR DISTANCE LEARNING. HOWEVER
EDUCATORS IN MANY SCHOOLS LACK
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
COST EFFECTIVELY PLAN FOR AND
IMPLEMENT CURRENT AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY TO SUPPORT
INSTRUCTIONAL. IT WITHOUT A
QUIT NEEDED STATE AND REGIONAL
FOCUS ON POLICY PROGRAMS OF
FUNDING. MANY DIFFERENT DO NOT
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO RESOURCES
NEEDED TO SELECT ACCESS
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY INTO
CLASSES AFFECTED LEE. AND
RESIDENTS ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES FROM THEIR HOMES NOW
AS WE SAW THE TRANSITION TO
DISTANCE LEARNING TO A COVERT
REALLY THAT MADE THIS BROUGHT
THIS FOR FRONT AND EXACERBATE
THIS ISSUE. CAN SHOW THE STARK
INEQUITIES BETWEEN DIFFERENT
CLASSROOMS IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF OUR STATE. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A STEP TOWARDS HELPING
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. IT
SUPPORTED BY COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AS A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE LINE WITH ME TODAY
WE HAVE BARBARA NEMCO NAPA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS. LRE OWNS THE CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICERBUT CEMETERY
ACCOUNTING OF A SPECIFICATION
GREAT TO OUR WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE- TWO MINUTES EACH POLICE
I BELIEVE THE FIRST. IS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF NAPPY NAPA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION YOU
MAY PROCEED. THE MOVE AND SAY
OH I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE.
HI COMMITTEE LISTENING TO MY
TESTIMONY I'VE BEEN IN
EDUCATION FOR MORE THAN FIFTEEN
YEARS AND THIS IS A PIVOTAL
MOMENT WE ARE BEING ASKED NOW
YOU JUST SPEECH BUT TO
ACCELERATE TO LEVERAGE TO CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AFTER
FOURTEEN MONTHS OF NOT HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE. PART AT.
THE FOR THE PANDEMIC WE KNOW
ESSENTIAL. INTEGRATION WHAT
IT'S BUT NOT EVERY TEACHER WAS
VERY PROFICIENT IN BEING ABLE
TO DO IT NOW EVEN THE LEAST BIT
INTERESTED IN TECHNOLOGY I HAD
TO LEARN THE BASIC WAYS OF
USING TECHNOLOGY IN THE
CLASSROOM BUT TECHNOLOGY IS THE
MOST POWERFUL TOOL WE HAVE. AND
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT EVERY
TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA WHETHER
THEY ARE IN THE SMALL WORLD FOR
LARGE URBAN DISTRICTS KNOW HOW
TO USE IT WELL ONE SO THAT WE
CAN DO WHAT THE LEGISLATUREIS
EXPECTING A LOT. WE'RE ALSO NOW
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF CYBER SECURITY AND WHEN YOU
THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
STATEMENTS THAT THE HEART OF
SILICON VALLEY HASN'T WORN
TECHNOLOGY PERSON IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
THAT'S ALMOST NOT CONSCIONABLE.
I DON'T WANT TO BE HYPERBOLIC
THIS IS NOT THE ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY BUT IT IS
CERTAINLY A ONCE IN A DECADE
OPPORTUNITY WHERE WE CAN
PROVIDE THREE PEOPLE IN THE
OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY WE CANNOT
LET THE COUNTY OFFICES. AT
FIFTY THIRD DISTRICT MAKING
SURE THAT EVERY FEATURE IS
ABSOLUTELY PROFICIENT
ABSOLUTELY CAPABLE OF PROVIDING
THE BEST TECHNOLOGY INTEGRATION
SO THAT WE GET MARKETS THAT
CHANCE TO COME BACK FROM WHAT
HAS BEEN A HORRIFIC LITTLE MORE
THAN A YEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I WOULD. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR GET. THANK YOU
SUPERINTEND WILL NOW PROCEED
TO- LAURIE- OWNS THE IT WAS A
WITH THE SAME COUNTY OFFICE OF.
ON THE PHONE. GOOD MORNING-
AGAIN MY NAME IS LAURIE-
ANTHONY CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
OFFICER FOR THE SAN MATTEO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
OVER MY TWENTY SIX YEAR CAREER
IN EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY I'VE
SEEN HOW TECHNOLOGY PROPERLY
SELECTED INTO THE APPROPRIATE
LEE DELIVERED. CANNOT ONLY
ENGAGE LARGER NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS AND THEIR LEARNING
EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO BETTER
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN
STUDENTS WHO ARE COMING FROM
HAVE ENVIRONMENT TO HAVE
SCHOOLS AND THOSE THAT ARE
COMING FROM THE HAVE NOTS
ENVIRONMENT AND HAVE NOT
SCHOOLS. I'VE ALSO PERSONALLY
WITNESSED THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
TECHNOLOGY WASTED AND EVEN EVEN
MORE IMPORTANTLY THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS IS LEARNING WHAT WAS
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BECAUSE THE
TECHNOLOGY YOU PURCHASED BUT
THEY'RE LEARNING WITH UNUSED OR
UNDERUTILIZED. MANY TIMES THE
REASON FOR THIS IS BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT THE INSTRUCTOR
CHARGED WITH TEACHING WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY HAD NOT BEEN
PROPERLY TRAINED AND WERE NOT
BEING PROPERLY SUPPORT IT. I
AND MY ONLY A STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WHILE WE
ALREADY KNEW ABOUT THE DIGITAL
DISPARITIES BETWEEN THE HAVES
AND THE HAVE NOTS BUT FOR THE
PANDEMIC THE PANDEMIC FOR UP
FOR THE HARSH SPOTLIGHT ON
THESE INEQUITIES. LAST MARCH
WHEN OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
TEACHERS WITH THE CALL TO
CONTINUE THE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FROM HOME SOME
SCHOOLS WERE ABLE TO FINISH
SCHOOL PUBLIC DEVICES THAT
WOULD TEACHERS FULLY TRAINED
AND WELL SUPPORTED IN
DELIVERING CURRICULUM
VIRTUALLY. ALL THAT IT'S MORE
THAN JUST KNOWING HOW TO
OPERATE THE DEVICE IT INVOLVES
THE PEDAGOGY NECESSARY TO
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER TECHNOLOGY
IN THIS MANNER. UP TO SCHOOLS
THAT WERE THE HAVE NOT UNDER
RESOURCE PRIMARILY SCHOOL I
WOULD STUDENTS OF COLOR WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO DO SO SOME OF THEM
WERE ABLE TO GATHER DEVICES
EVENTUALLY IN DISBURSING THE
STUDENTS BUT THE ONE AREA THEY
WERE NOT EASILY ABLE TO FIT IT
IN USE IN THE TEACHING OF
SUPPORTING. OF INSTRUCTORS IN
THE MOST EFFECTIVE METHODS TO
DELIVER ITS CURRICULUM IF EACH
OTHER BEEN IN EXISTENCE. WHEN
THE PANDEMIC CAME UPON US MANY
ABOUT NOT ONLY AIDS WHATEVER TO
REACH TO GO TO BUT IT WAS NOT.
THAT IS WHAT AT SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL PROVIDE. ONE THING WE DO
KNOW. EMERGENCY SOMERS. WE ARE
THE PORT. OF THE BILL WILL ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO PLEASE-
SUPPORT. SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
WELL DONE THANK YOU- WITH THAT
WE GO TO- ARE THERE AND THEY'RE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SENIOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE-
TWENTY MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS SINGLE QUOTE A
QUESTIONS READY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL GO TO- COMMENT IN
THE ROOM A PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE ROOM. OVER AND UNDER THE
FULL. THANK YOU ARE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR TEN
MINUTES. THE MODERATOR FOR
TEMAS SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
AND THIS IS FOR SB SEVEN SIX
SEVEN ONLY ONLY. JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
THANK YOU- TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR AT SB SEVEN SIX
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZEROS
WHAT'S SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND FINALLY
SOMEBODY QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. EVERYBODY ELSE GOING AT
ONE ZERO NOW TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR SB. SEVEN SIX
SEVEN. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS TREES MERRY CHRYSLER-
CONTRACTED EVALUATOR OF
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. MAKE
SURE WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- LET'S GO TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION CAPITAL
PARKER'S OR ANYONE PRESENT.
THERE IS NO ONE PRESENT IN
CAPITOL PARK- THE AUTHOR MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU ARE FOR THE
COMMENTS FROM THE WITNESSES
THAT THE TECH EDUCATION
TECHNOLOGIES ONLY CAN WERE MORE
IMPORTANT AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR- SUPPORT- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE FOR SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU KNOW WE
ARE GOING TO DO IS TAKE ONE
WITNESS IN THE ROOM WHO ALREADY
PREVIOUSLY CAME UP AT A
MICROPHONE WAS OFF. AND THAT IS
NOT HER FAULT. MICHAEL K. THERE
WE GO LETY SIGUR C. ON BEHALF
OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT WITH THAT AND WE
HAVE CLOSE WE HAVE WE DON'T
MOTION AND A SECOND- DO WE HAVE
THE MOTIONS. OF THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI DONNA HI KYLIE
KYLIE I BET IT. BENNETT I DALY.
ALII LEA LEE I MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE CORK SILVA. PORK SILVA I
SEVEN SIX US COULD COULD JUMP
INTO SEVERAL TO ACTUALLY WELL
DONE. THANK YOU. WELL NOW GO TO
EITHER. SB TWO FIVE FOR THIS-
SENATOR BORDERS HERE. LET'S ON
CONSENT LONG WAIVER SENATOR
RUBIO WHO. THEN HEADING HERE
WHILE I THINK RIGHT. SO WHEN WE
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. YOU
HAVE A LISTING MOTION OF OUR-
MOST IT IS WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED BY MR LEE. FILE ITEM
ONE SB TWO FIFTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR THE DONALD. HI DONALD I
KILEY. KILEY I'D BENNETT
BENNETT I DALLY. DALLY I'LL
LEAVE LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY I
QUICK SILVA. CORPS OF I. THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AS PASSED.
DO WE HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON
CENTER. THE DANCER YEAH THAT'S
GOOD START. DO THEY HAVE ANY
FEEDBACK OR.
YEAH. THEREFORE
THE TOTAL FASTER OKAY. YEAH.
THE THREE KD EDUCATION.
TRANSACTION. YEAH.
TO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER NUMBERS TO AND FOR
TWO AND FOUR FILE ITEM TWO SB
THREE SIXTY THREE THE CHAIR
VOTING I MCCARTY MCCARTY I
FIFTH FILE ITEM FOR SB SIX
NINETY THREE THE CHAIR VOTING I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I.
FOR THE
PROBLEM. THERE SHE IS. ALL
RIGHT LET US- MOVED- SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO AGAIN
THIS FILE ITEM THREE. YOU MAY
PROCEED GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
MESSAGER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ME TO BE HERE TO
PRESENT TODAY MY SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT HAS BEEN IN
PRODUCTION FOR THREE YEARS WITH
A LOT OF COLLABORATION AND
STAKEHOLDER INPUT FIRST I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO CAME TO
THE TABLE AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE- COMMITTEE.
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. SO SB
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT MAKES
NECESSARY CHANGES IN ORDER TO
DRIVE BETTER READING
COMPREHENSION OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING TO REVISE
THEIR TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAM STANDARDS. AND TEACHING
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS FOR
LITERACY BY SEPTEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ADDITIONALLY
IT ALLOWS CANDIDATES WHO HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO TAKE THE RICA
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC TO TAKE CDC
APPROVED ASSESSMENT READING
INSTRUCTION AND FINALLY A
REQUIRES A CTC TO UPDATE THE
TEACHER PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
T. P. ACE TO REPLACE THE RICA
BY JULY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE T. P. A.'S ARE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED GOLD
STANDARD FOR CANDIDATES
ASSESSMENTS AND ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH THE ONLY ASSESSMENT
THAT HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
SIGNIFICANTLY PROTECT TEACHER
EFFECTIVENESS. THE CORE OF THIS
BILL IS WILL BE TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING THE
PROPER AN EVIDENCE BASED
READING INSTRUCTION IN CLASS
WHICH IS FOUNDATIONAL FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS. SB FORTY EIGHT
UPDATES ASSESSMENTS OF READING
INSTRUCTION COMPETENCE AS WELL
AS TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS. WHICH IS CRITICAL AND
NECESSARY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ALL STUDENTS. SEARCH AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY TWO
WITNESSES WHO WILL PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY BY PHONE. FIRST
I HAVE DOCTOR LYNN SCOTT THE
TEACHER PREPARATION EDUCATOR
AND PROFESSOR AT CSU EAST BAY.
AT ALSO ON THE PHONE I HAVE
DOCTOR PERMANENT ADMINISTRATIVE
COORDINATOR AT ALLEY UST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I WILL GO TO THE-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE WITH TWO MINUTES EACH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WHAT IS
YOUR LIFE SHOULD BE ALL BUT
JUST ON MUTE YOUR PHONE. GOOD
MORNING CAROL DONALD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR
LYNN SCOTT A TENURE LINE
FACULTY MEMBER IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. MY EXPERTISE IS IN THE
READING INSTRUCTION AND BY
LITERACY. I PREPARE TEACHER
CANDIDATES IN THE COLLEGE OF
BAY'S TEACHER EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT. OUR STATE
ACCREDITED PROGRAM IS RIGOROUS
CANDIDATES MUST SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE COURSEWORK THAT
ALLIANCE TO COMMISSION
STANDARDS. AND AT LEAST SIX
HUNDRED HOURS OF. CLASSROOM
TEACHING SUPERVISED BY A EX. IN
TRAIN MENTOR. AND THE MONTHS
PASSED PERFORMANCE AFFECT IN
LITTLE AND MATH MATH. BY
DOCUMENTING THEIR T. WITHIN AND
WRITTEN AND HAVE BEEN SUBMIT
THERE WERE FOR ABOUT. BY NOW
SPORTS. EACH CAN'T. ALSO MY
PASS THE OUTER BAY WE GOT. THE
RECALL IS FLAWED TWO. WAYS
FIRST IT HAS NOT BEEN SHOWN TO
HAVE PREDICTIVE VALIDITY WE DO
NOT KNOW THAT THE TEACHER WHO
PASSES THE RICA IS A BETTER.
TEACHER THAN SOMEONE WHO DOES
NOT. TEACHING SUCH THAT. HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO PROVE TEACHER
EFFECTIVENESS. SECOND THERE WE
COULD DOES NOT ALIGN WITH
CURRENT STATED OFTEN STANDARDS
OR FRAMEWORKS SUCH AS OUR STATE
ADOPTED THE L. A. E. L. B.
FRAMEWORK WHICH EMPHASIZES THE
FIVE BEANS OF MEANING MAKING
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT AFFECTED
EXPRESSION CONTENT KNOWLEDGE
AND FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS.
EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTION INCLUDING
ALL FIVE TEAM SUPPORTS THE
READING SUCCESS OF ALL STUDENTS
AND IS A SPECIALLY CRITICAL FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS WE NEED
TEACHERS TO WITH THE MOST UP TO
DATE- GAJI TO EFFECTIVELY TEACH
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
STREET. IN CONCLUSION SEVENTY
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT ENSURES THAT
THE ABILITY TO TEACH READING OF
THE FACTS THROUGH STATE
APPROVED TEACHING PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT BASED ON CURRENT
STANDARDS SO THAT NEW
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY ARE WELL
PREPARED TO TEACH THEIR
STUDENTS. HOW TO READ. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR WILL MOVE ON
TO- PATRICIA PERRIN. IN SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DR
PATRICIA CRONIN AND I REPRESENT
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COORDINATOR IN CHARGE OF OUR
INTERN CREDENTIALING AND ADDED
AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM OR I
CAN'T WHAT ANGELES UNIFIED IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WE GOT HAS
BEEN A HIGH HURDLE FOR MANY OF
OUR CANDIDATES. SOMETIMES THEY
WOULD PASS ONE PARK AND THAT
NOT ANOTHER ONLY TO RETAKE THE
ENTIRE EXAM AGAIN DATA
INDICATES THE RVCA IS
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT FOR
TEACHERS TO HAVE ENGLISH AS
THEIR SECOND LANGUAGE SH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT PASSING CAN
BE DRAMATIC IF THEY AREN'T ABLE
TO PASS THE EXAM AND IF THEY'VE
EXHAUSTED THEIR PERMIT OPTION.
PROVISIONAL INTERN PERMITS ARE
SHORT TERM STOCK PERMITTED OR
EVEN THEIR INTERN CREDENTIALING
OP OPTION THEY CANNOT TO BE
HIRED BY THE DISTRICT AS A FULL
TIME TEACHER THE TEACHERS MAY
HAVE COMPLETED THEIR ENTIRE
TEACHER PREP PROGRAMS PASSING
THE GPA AND RECOMMENDED BY THE
PROGRAM WHERE THEY WILL PREPARE
TO BE AN EFFECTIVE EDUCATOR
ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT THEY WERE
NOT ABLE TO TEACH DUE TO AN
OUTDATED. EXAM BY USING HEPA
SETTING THE TEACHER IS THEN IN
A NATURAL ENVIRONMENT ALLOWING
FOR AN AUTHENTIC ASSESSMENT FOR
THE MORE TEACHERS TO PAST
WEEKEND DO NOT PRODUCE HIGHER
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND THOSE
WHO FAIL BY CONTRAST SCORES OF
THE TEACHER PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT LIKE THE AT G. P. H.
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY PREDICTED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY PROTECT. TEACHERS%
AFFECTED THAT THE TEACHING
READING EXTENDING THE
FLEXIBILITY SINCE ONE MORE
ACTION THE LEGISLATION CAN TAKE
TO CONTINUE TO TEAR DOWN
BARRIERS TO ENTER INTO THE
TEACHING PROFESSION AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROSPECTIVE EDUCATORS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ATTAINING. FULL
CERTIFICATION FOR THESE REASONS
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED URGES YOUR
I DOUBT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE ONE WITNESS
IN A IN OPPOSITION. MAJORIS
PORTER I BELIEVE. YEAH YES
HELLO MY NAME IS WOULD LIKE TO
ORDER AND I AM. I HAVE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA.
FOR PARENTS CHILDREN ADVOCACY
NORTH CAPITA BUT WE ARE AN ALL
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
WITH CHILDREN WHO HAVE
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE PREVIOUSLY UP PROPOSED-
THE RICO LAST THE LEGISLATION
SB SIX FOURTEEN LAST YEAR BOB
BUT OUR OPPOSITION IS REALLY
INTENDED TO BE VERY
COLLABORATIVE. IN WORKING WITH
SENATOR RUBIO'S OFFICE TO
DEVELOP A CURRICULUM READING
CURRICULUM THAT WILL ACTUALLY
HELP OUR STUDENTS. AND I SEE
THAT AFTER OUR CLOUT OPPOSITION
LAST YEAR THERE WERE SOME
REALLY SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES IN
TERMS OF NOT ELIMINATING THE
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF THAT-
SCIENTIFIC BASED READING AND
ACTUALLY IT ADDS IT RESULTED IN
A REALLY POSITIVE RESULTS IN
TERMS. OF ADOPTING. TH
DYSLEXIA GUIDELINE OF WHAT SO
WE ARE NOT. OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BUT WE OPPOSED IT ONLY IN A
COLLABORATIVE. SO THAT OUR
CHILDREN END UP WITH A REALLY-
BENEFICIAL BILL THAT WILL
ACTUALLY HELP THEM. OUR BIGGEST
ISSUE RIGHT NOW I MEAN BUT SOME
OF THE- BIGGER ISSUE BUT WE
DON'T WE DO NOT OPPOSE BECAUSE
OF THE FACT. THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN CHANGES AND WE HAD THE
BILL DOES MOVE TOWARDS A
SCIENTIFIC BASED READING SO
WE'RE NOT YOU KNOW ARGUING
AGAINST THAT. I THINK THE
BIGGEST ISSUE RIGHT NOW REALLY
HAS TO DO WITH THE TEACHER
CREDENTIALING I AM AN AFRICAN.
I'M AN AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN
WHO ALSO IS OF AMERICAN INDIAN
AND LATINO THE FACT. I'M JOE I
AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TEACHERS OF COLOR NOT BEING IN
THE PAST BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE RECAP I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY
BE ABLE TO PASS A TEST BATCH
HAS READING CURRICULA. YEAH AND
I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD YOUR
PERFORMANCE TEST WOULD BE THE
BEST AT MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ACTUALLY FIVE LOOK AT THOSE
CATS AND WE WEREN'T. ABLE TO
GET SOMETHING. SO I WE CAN TO
OPPOSE IT- BECAUSE RISE.RIGHT
WE ARE OPPOSING THE PORTION OF
THE BILL THAT- ELIMINATE THE
TAKING OF THE BEACON CAST AND
WE ARE OPPOSE THE GPAS ARE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE EFFECTIVE IN
DEMONSTRATING THE ABILITY TO
TEACH. THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WILL BRING IT BACK TO- COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAYING NINE WE WILL- GO
TO- IN THE ROOM A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM. HI LETY
SECRECY ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM ANY PERSONS IN
THE ROOM SINGLE PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM- WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES
FOR TEN MINUTES ON THE PHONES
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE ON THE PHONES.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE'RE ON SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT IS THAT CORRECT MISTER
CHAIR. CORRECT THANK YOU SORT
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
S. B. FOUR EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WILL BEGIN WITH
LIKE TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
FAIR ABOUT JUST WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS AND SUPPORT.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AMERICA ROCKS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JERRY DONALD
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS MY NAME
THREATEN TO KEEP FOR THE
EXPECTATION OF PROPERTY SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. BUT ABOUT
FORTY. WITH TWENTY EIGHT YOU
ARE UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. RENDON
TO ACT ON BEHALF OF ADVICE AND
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY ONE YOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. H. GOOD MORNING
MR TERROR MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
CHRIS THREE PHAM BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. I AM
FORTY THREE TO FORTY YARDS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KENNY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
TOURISM ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB FORTY
THANK YOU. FIND TWENTY YOUR
OPEN. THANK TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE YOU MUTED LINE
TWENTY ONE MORE CHANCE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TWENTY. ARE
MOVING ALONG WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY TWO FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
GOING AT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT. NINE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GRAYSON
ALLEN WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I MISSED RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU
BEING EFFICIENT BOB WITH THAT
LET'S BRING IT BACK- AND THE
OTHER MAY CLOSE. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I JUST WANNA
THANK THE CHAIR AS I STATED
IT'S BEEN A THREE YEARS IN THE
MKING ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION YOURSELF IN YOUR
COMMITTEE I THINK WE'VE COME TO
A GOOD. MIDDLE GROUND I THINK
THAT I WANT TO JUST MAKE CLEAR
THIS IS A BILL THAT I WANTED TO
TAKE ON AS THAT SEVENTEEN YEAR
VETERAN TEACHER BECAUSE I
UNDERSTOOD THAT. THE WAY THAT
THE REGAL IS SET UP IT NO
LONGER. IS IN ALIGNMENT WITH
HOW WE TEACH IN THE CLASSROOM I
WAS IN THE CLASSROOM WHEN
COMMON CORE CAME INTO WITH INTO
EXISTENCE AND IT REALLY. IS NO
LONGER EFFECTIVE THE WAY WE
WERE TEACHING- SO I REALLY JUST
WANT TO. YOU KNOW SAY THIS
AGAIN THIS IS WHAT'S BEST FOR
STUDENTS NOT NECESSARY IN MY
OPINION FOR TEACHERS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. STUDENTS HAVE
THE BEST TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THIS HAS TWO
COMPONENTS- JUST OP I THINK I
HEARD A COMMENT JOHN THIS IS
ALSO HELPING TEACHERS DEVELOP
LESSON PLANS BEING ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THEM IN THE
CLASSROOM. AND BEING ABLE TO
PERFORM IN THE CLASSROOM AND I
THINK ALL OF THAT TOGETHER
MAKES FOR BETTER TEACHERS AND
MORE EDUCATED STUDENTS SO WITH
THAT I ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU JUST TO CONFIRM
YOU DO SUPPORT THE YOU DO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT JESSICA.
THANK YOU. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
I'VE THAT'S THE BEST AND IT'S
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED. BILL'S
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION AS HE
PASSES A MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS
OF DONALD. AYE MADONNA AYE
KILEY AYE. KILEY AYE BENNETT.
BENNETT I DALLY. DALLY I LEAVE.
LEE I MCCARTY MCCARTY I QUIT
SILVA WORKS OF I. GREAT I JUST
WANT TO COMMENT THE CONSULTANT
I LOVE HERE MISS LIEBERMAN
SPENT A LOT OF TIME. I KNOW
THAT ON THIS BILL IN THE FALL
AND THEN SOME AFTER THE FALL
SO- THERE'S A RIGHT THERE I
WANT TO MAKE IT A BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES IT IS OUT. YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT-
OKAY AT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.